all right Monica yes Monica where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
originally I'm from Poland grew up in
Sweden and moved to the states about
eight years ago now
and tell me about your childhood you had
both parents uh I grew up in Poland
um very Catholic home
um grew up with my mom my dad was a
severe alcoholic
um he beat my mom in front of me he beat
my grandparents in front of me I
remember it even though as I was three
years old I still remember it
um my parents divorced while we actually
had to run out of there
because my dad was very abusive so we
moved in with my grandpa and my grandma
and me and my mom lived with them
um so yeah it was it was pretty pretty
rough I was I was abused a lot not not
by my dad but by my mom
um so I I had a hard childhood
um my mom I remember my mom going to
Sweden and she stayed away for about a
year and I was very small and she came
back and she said she married somebody
and we're moving to Sweden and I was
absolutely heartbroken because I really
loved my grandma and my grandpa so I
didn't want to move and I remember
crying when they were packing me in the
car because I was so upset because now I
know nobody can protect me and now I'm
moving with my mom and God knows I don't
like Dad like the new dad because I
didn't know him I never met him before
we moved so I had no idea who he was
um so my mom never gave me a chance to
like him or dislike him we were just
moving to him and that was basically it
so I moved to Sweden when I was about
four or five years old
very tough we're living in a small
community in Sweden I went to a school
where there was basically no immigrants
at that point it was 1989 so I was the
only one together with
one other girl that was from Poland too
I was severely bullied in school because
I didn't know how to speak Swedish in
the beginning so I have to be I had to
go to homeschooling first for Swedish so
I could learn and I had a guy that was
walking with me always in school he was
my translator so I was very ashamed and
I was very bullied because we were
pretty poor as well when we moved
because my dad was the only one working
my stepdad
um so I never had anything everything I
had was hand-me-downs and if I asked my
mom if I could get something she would
say no and I would ask why and she was
like just because because I say so there
was never like well we don't really have
money it was always I was never
important
um so that kind of affected me
um a lot during my childhood
um I remember one time like for example
I forgot my jacket in school my mom has
just just bought me a jacket I forgot it
it was on a Friday it's not a big deal
kids forget jackets you know
I came home and my mom was like where's
your jacket and I was like well I forgot
it at school I'll get it on Monday and
she was like well
um well so you have a choice I was like
okay she was very angry at me she's like
you have a choice either I'll whip you
10 times or you stay at you'll stay at
home while we go out in the dark like
she would turn all the lights off and I
wasn't allowed to turn them on if she
found out that I turn them on when they
were in home she would beat me again
so I chose to be beaten because I was
scared to be home alone
um and I was nine years old
so and she beat me like with a garden
hose so I had big like bruises on my
butt
um
it was really tough because
I didn't understand why I was treated
like that I was just a child and I
haven't done anything you know so that
was that was the abuse I grew up with
um and it gotten it got worse
um my Dad tried to protect me as good as
he can he could he was a good guy in the
end like he was he was amazing and I
loved him a lot but my mom just told him
it's not your kid stay out of it some
step dad you're talking about yeah my
stepdad yeah and stay out of it it's not
your you know she was very abusive
towards him she would call him names and
stuff like that and he was a very mellow
guy so he never fought back
um but he he did try
um to you know get her away from me but
um but she would she would beat me
really bad once she hit me in the in the
face with a fist I had bruises I went to
school I I told on her because I was
like this is the only way to get out of
the situation
and they took my mom in and she said
straight up that I was lying I fell down
and I was lying and because she I didn't
want to do my chores so I got upset with
her so I went to school and lied and the
teachers bought it and it wasn't the
first time I came to with bruises to
school like I would that would happen
often I would be scared to go home
um but never nobody ever did anything
because my mom would just come in and
lie and say that I I you know I lied to
them because I was angry with her and
they always bought it so I I had nobody
literally nobody who can help me I
and I didn't understand what I was
treated like that I wasn't allowed to
have friends over I wasn't allowed to go
to birthday parties I wasn't allowed to
go out my mom would love love to punish
me
um every time I did something wrong it
could be a small thing or I didn't do
anything
it like
you know something could have happened
and I was blamed and I would always get
hit by my mom so my mom took every
opportunity to beat the living crap out
of me
and my dad couldn't do anything so
obviously when I grew up I was very
rebellious
um I would run away from home I would
hook up with guys I would put myself in
trouble
um
I almost got raped once
um and it was I was just trying to do
anything to get away from her and she
always found out
uh what I did
um so
she would find me and beat me in front
of my friends I remember once she told
me I was about
15 maybe
um
I went out with some friends because we
had like a garden party in the little
town I lived in and a lot of my friends
were out you know bicycles whatever we
had a good time I went out with them and
my mom was there too and she didn't like
that I went up with friends so she
literally beat me in front of all my
friends and made me walk home
I have never been so humiliated in my
life I wanted to kill myself like it was
the worst thing ever and after that the
bullying just escalated like people with
egg or house
they would toss garbage into her yard
um
they would stand outside our house and
scream like profanities
um it was it was very very tough so I
actually ran away from home
um I was
I was sleeping in people's couches I
moved in with a guy that was a drug
addict
um and we lived under very harsh in a
very harsh environment he was a drug
addict we never had money
I had to shoplift to get clothes or food
I had to beg my dad to buy us food
um just because we didn't have any money
I was very young I was like 16 and he
was 20.
um but finally I got out of there and I
went to uh to a foster foster family
um and that was horrible because I ended
up in a home that was the mom was an
alcoholic
um so she was very abusive as well I
remember one time I was doing the dishes
because we all had chores that we had to
do I was doing the dishes and it was
like a plastic container that wasn't
like super super clean because I missed
something and she she flipped out she
would throw it at me and call me names
and said I was worthless and she said
while I don't I understand why your mom
doesn't love you
um things like that so when I was I
lived there for a year and I just
couldn't live there anymore
um so I actually got my own apartment
um but the problem was I was so young I
did have a job I I I didn't go to school
I just I didn't finish because I just
dropped out
um
what was the deal with your mom was she
just she she didn't care problems or
yeah religious or what my my mom my mom
is has narcissistic personality disorder
and she's also bipolar she doesn't
medicate she self-medicates she says
that she's not an alcoholic but she
drinks every day
um she says she doesn't take pills but
she takes uh pills every day and she
could prescribe them for herself because
she's a doctor
um so she would take painkillers every
single day and drink but she says she's
not an alcoholic and she doesn't have a
problem I am the problem and whatever
problem she has in her life I made I
created and she literally told me she
wishes I was dead were you an only child
yes
um she did get pregnant again but she
had an abortion because she told me she
didn't want to have a kid one more kid
that would turn out like me but my mom
got abused when she was a kid as well
um really like my grandpa has a heavy
hand and she was beaten quite badly and
she just continued to do the same to me
um so of course
it was just bad I would I would hook up
hook up with guys
um I did get pregnant once I was so
scared to tell my mom so I wanted to
have an abortion because I knew if I
told my mom she will beat the living
hell out of me like she will kill me
literally I knew she would kill me she
would beat me so much I'd die so I was
like what am I gonna do so I went to the
clinic and they told me that oh you
don't like they do an ultrasound and
they say well it doesn't look like
you're pregnant it looks like a
um
it doesn't look like a real pregnancy so
probably aborted I was like okay so I
didn't worry about it
then all of a sudden I was four months
pregnant
they misdiagnosed it
um and I had to tell my mom and I I was
like I'm gonna kill myself I actually
went out and wanted to take my own life
but I didn't have the guts to do it
so I just went home and told her and she
I mean I she was Furious but she didn't
beep me but she took me to the doctor
straight away she was like we're doing
an abortion
and the doctor was like she's four and a
half months pregnant they were like my
mom was like I don't care it has to go
um so I had an abortion in four and a
half months
I had to have a delivery I delivered
um the baby my mom made me look at the
dead baby she was like this is what you
did you killed your own child
so I had to look at it
um which I still remember
and I almost died because
I am
I lost so much blood so I died on the
operating table and uh
I came out and um
my mom was like
um
well you did this to yourself so
um it suits you right and she was like I
wish I wish you didn't make it and um I
was so upset because all I wanted for my
mom was to love me and she didn't
um so after that
um
I uh that's when I ran away and got my
own apartment I ended up in in Social
care and stuff and then I had my own
apartment but the problem was like I
worked but I didn't have enough money to
pay rent so
um
so my mom had to help me and uh
she actually did which is weird
um but she also said that I have to do
whatever she says
um
and she would she would literally call
me every single day to check on me if I
was at home if I was out somewhere or
doing anything she would literally drive
to my apartment and beat the living [__]
out of me
so I was so scared I was just sitting at
home because
every time the phone rang I just I just
didn't know what to do like I was so
scared of her even though I didn't live
with her
um
so I lived in my apartment and then I
met my ex
um
and I was like okay
I like him he's cool he's nice he was 10
years older than me
um so I after a couple of months I moved
in with him just to get away from my mom
because I thought maybe if I live with
him she won't do this to me anymore
the problem is he was just like her
um so I just I just did the same thing
all over again I just ran to somebody
that is just like my mom
he wasn't physically abusive but
mentally
um and it was for 11 years
because
I didn't my mom was like if you leave
him I will never talk to you again
and I was like I have nobody
um so for some odd reason I don't know
why I have this weird attachment to my
mom where when she says something I go
like I'll do whatever you want
um so I never left him for 11 years and
he was he was mentally abusive he
he was yelling at me he it was just me
walking in eggshells every day I came
home from work or school like I it I was
so scared of doing anything wrong that
I every time I came home I just wanted
to throw up because I knew he was home
and that I have to watch myself
like I have to do everything he wants
but still even if I did everything he
wanted
he still was upset and I and I like it's
hard to explain the feeling of
hopelessness
where you just want to kill yourself
because you feel like whatever you do
doesn't help like you do things but you
you're such a good person you try to do
good things but they just don't you know
whatever you do is is wrong
hope
yeah it's like I have nobody and that is
it
um
but thankfully after 11 years
um I went to school I finished my degree
I went to the university I became a
teacher
um and I had nobody's support my mom
wouldn't support me she said yeah you're
going to the university getting like a
[__] degree like you're becoming a
teacher that's just nothing you can be
so much you can be something so much
better but she's like but I guess you
just don't want to try
um I just wanted to become a teacher
because I wanted to help kids that are
being abused or you know going through
things
um so I did I worked for as a teacher
for for two years
um and it was it was very tough because
of the upbringing I had and I did see a
lot of the same Tendencies and I just
couldn't do it because I had not you
know I haven't worked with my trauma
back then
so I still had like PTSD and I just I
was like I can't I can't I can't do this
I can't see it because whatever I say
doesn't help and I can't stop these
parents to treat their kids badly so I I
just felt like a failure so I quit
so I started working
um as a receptionist and stuff like that
and a project manager I did have really
good jobs
um so I was just working I left my ex my
mom and I stopped talking
um she would invite him for Christmas
and not me I would sit by myself on
Christmas
um she would call him 20 times a day she
never called me
um
and then one day out of the blue I
remember she called me and she was like
well we shouldn't be fighting I was like
well I didn't start it I just left the
person that was abusive but you took his
side so I don't
I don't really know what what to say and
she just said well you did the wrong
thing you always do the wrong things you
never
um you never act right you're always a
burden you know
but she was like but I'm still your mom
so I guess you know I have to talk to
you I'm like you don't have to like you
there is nothing you have to do you
don't have to talk to me
um but but you know we we did started
talking again everything was fine for a
little bit and then she went back to her
cycle of being abusive
um
so I had to cut contact again
because I said okay I can't do this
you're being abusive again this is not I
can't live with this
um and then she called me again and it
was fine we started talking
and at that same time I met my husband
we met on Facebook through similar
through friends and we started talking
and she could not stand that this is
this is where the worst period of
besides being beat this was
psychological Terror I've never
experienced anything like this
so we started talking me me and my
husband online and you know when you
when you meet up first you talk about
everything you know from sex to you know
everything because you knew you're in
love it's all fun and we did talk about
a lot of like
sexual stuff but that's our private
business right that's not nobody should
be involved in that but we started
talking we talked every day we talked a
lot and my mom couldn't stand up because
now this is there is a new man that's
taking her control away from her over me
um because my husband was very
supportive and he was like you know you
have to break free from the abuse you
can't you can't be in this because
you'll kill yourself like this is not
good for you
um it was very supportive so I felt like
I finally had the support to kind of
pull back and and say you know this is
enough I'm not doing this with you
um so I started doing that and the it's
she could not stand this like this was
the worst thing so
she hacked my Facebook
she hacked my Facebook and she saw all
the messages we were sending back and
forth
and that's when the help what the hell
broke loose I remember when when I was I
was in the states visiting him and she
calls me
and she was like you shouldn't be with
him and she was yelling and she was
calling me I'm I'm a [__] and
everything and I didn't really
understand where this came from because
it was such a weird reaction
I was like where is this coming from but
I found out when I got home
she was she would send me screenshots of
the conversations we had on Facebook and
she was like I'm gonna go to the police
with this I'm gonna I'm gonna see two
that you will never leave Sweden you
will never leave me
um so she went to the police the police
called me she handed over she printed
out everything from that Facebook
conversation including
pictures that I would send him and he
would send me like the police saw
everything all the private conversations
and I just wanted to die when I when I
walked into that police station I was
like this is the worst this is so
horrible and I have to look these people
in the eye and explain myself
and I came in and I was like listen
we're all grown here we're adults I'm
I'm 30 years old like this is a private
conversation I have with somebody I'm
dating and and the guy was like well you
know
your mom is worried this and that and I
was like I am grown person like you
can't do this to me why am I here this
is very embarrassing for me
um and I said that I they actually
granted me a um
um
um a restriction a restraining order uh
for 30 days so they can investigate it
so my mom wasn't wasn't allowed to be
near me but she would still send me
emails I didn't send them to to the
police because I just wanted to be over
with
um but she said that she had hired
people to follow me
um and stuff like that just to see what
I was doing
and at that time I started dancing in
Copenhagen on Fridays and Saturdays uh
so she found out and she said that I
have P she would call the club to ask me
if I was there and to ask what kind of
Club it is what are they doing
um
it was just so horrible she got me
kicked out of my apartment I had I had
30 days to leave because she told the
landlord that I was a prostitute and I
had men outside my my door and I was
selling sexual favors
uh so I got kicked out I had 30 days to
leave and I had nowhere to go
um
I did find an apartment thankfully uh
but she called my husband's mom
that was seven two years old and told
her all our private conversations and
screenshot it like conversations between
me and my husband to his mom
and his mom calls him and says who is
this person what is this what is
happening and he was like I like don't
take it seriously
um but yeah she it was horrible she cut
she called the American Embassy to get
me not to come to the U.S and I had to
call the American Embassy and be like
um I'm sorry has my mom called they're
like yes I was like Ugh and they were
laughing and I was dying inside they're
like if we're gonna listen to every nut
job that calls in here about stuff we
this is all we'll be doing you're fine
like we don't take this seriously so you
finally got away yeah I finally came to
the states
unfortunately the trauma I have is never
feeling good enough after this and
that's how I got into the adult industry
when I came here I didn't have a green
card so I started dancing and that was
all fine because it was just a bikini
Club so it wasn't anything any nudity at
that time
um so you know it was fun I was dancing
but then things escalated because I went
from one thing to another and I actually
did
um I did go into porn I did four movies
I think all together and I remember the
first time I was going to Vegas to do a
video and I was just I cried in the car
I was I was like okay but it's either
this or rent
I have to pay rent so I have to do this
but I wanted to kill myself
because this was so out of my element
worst eight hours of my life it was so
horrific
it was just so harsh and it was
it was two guys so you know it was just
very harsh
so I did that and of course once you've
done that and once they released the
video and the interest starts to grow
for you
you just forget how bad it made you feel
and you just close off to the world and
you just keep on going
um it was I did four more after that
but I just had to get out because the
last one I I I've never been so
depressed in my life it was horrific I
wanted I didn't want to kill myself
um I it was just it was all over the
Internet and every time I heard about it
or saw it
I I was like take everything down I'll
pay anybody to take it down like I don't
care
but since I had a contract nobody could
take anything down like it was on the
internet
um
but as I I passed it I was like I'm not
doing this anymore
I started dancing again and I danced at
a pay-to-play club
um which was eight hours of men one
Monday to Friday
which was even worse
um so I closed off to the world
um I
I pushed my husband away I didn't want
to have anything to do with him
he
um
he was so sick of it he had a hard time
it was just very very bad in our
relationship I I literally wanted to
move back home because I felt like I
wanted to run back to my mom
um and it is so weird after all this
time and after everything she did every
time I get upset or something is hard I
want to run back to my mom but that's
never gonna happen so
I just kept on doing what I was doing
and
I was I was dancing in this club and it
was just horrible it was dark in there
you couldn't see anything it was just
and they made you like
if you want to make money you get to do
this and this and this you know and it
was just so horrific I did that for five
years
um
and then I quit because
like enough is enough
I can't do this anymore and thankfully
only fans started at that time
and I started only fans
um 2017.
and it was really really good
um I felt more relaxed with doing what I
wanted to do and not really
being told what to do
um so I I started doing a little solo
stuff and then I started doing stuff
with my husband and then we started
doing more and more and more you know
with other people and stuff like that
and that was fine up to a degree
and now I'm just finding myself in the
same situation where it's just getting
hard
um
and I think what has gotten me to this
position right now why I chose do do
adult
is because I've never felt like I was
good enough for anybody
um and I think that's the case with a
lot of
people that are in the adult industry we
we suffer we did suffer a lot of us
suffered a lot of trauma and a lot of us
feel like we're not worthy or we're not
worthy of somebody's love so we're just
trying to find
people to love us and appreciate us and
we find these this through adult because
when we show ourselves off or you know
the naked body and stuff like that we
feel appreciated when men appreciates us
um for me it's the lack of being loved
um really loved by a parent no matter
what I've never had unconditional love
in my life I don't know what that is
um I
I
[Music]
just wanted to have that for my parents
and I feel like when I'm online I have
that unconditional love from other
people
and sometimes I feel like I'm not good
enough for my husband that he is ashamed
of me and what I do
even though he's a part of it it's
different for a guy but I sometimes feel
that
I don't make people proud
um and that people are ashamed of me
um but I still do this for
self-perception or do you think it's
what you're really getting from him uh
no I think I think it's my my lack of
self-worth
um that puts me in this position I think
what it is is that
I've I've never felt unconditional love
and that's what I think I think that he
doesn't love me
really like for real he he he thinks I'm
good looking and stuff like that but in
my own head I'm I'm always oh you know
even if this ends I'll be fine
um because I shelter myself from that so
I was like I'll be fine because he
doesn't really love me he says he loves
me but my mom said she loved me but that
she did all these things and
that's why if he says he loves me I feel
like he just says that because my mom
said it she didn't mean it so why should
he and I really don't feel
I don't feel like I've ever been loved
or appreciated for real like I always
feel like it's gonna end or it's a lie
or I'll try to do something to sabotage
it for myself so I can say I told you so
um so it's just hard it's it's it's hard
trauma to work through because
you push yourself into such situations
that you wouldn't normally do if you
didn't have to if you didn't have
baggage
I I put myself in so many very
frightening situations that I shouldn't
have been in I mean I've I've lived with
a drug addict I've I've I've been raped
you know I've been
I I don't want to say I've been molested
but kind of
um we had when I was this was when I was
13 we had like workers at our house they
were painting the outside of the house
and after it was like my dad's friends
um
my stepdad's friends and they were like
drinking in the end of the evening
and um we're all sitting and having
dinner and they were like drinking it
was a little party
and one of these guys I don't know how
old he was he was like in his early 30s
or late 20s something like that
and
my dad was like oh he likes you I'm like
I was 13. I don't know what that is like
I whatever
um
and he
he literally groped me and everybody was
laughing
and they're like oh he's just joking
but
and they left me with him everybody went
in and they left me with him like I had
to tell my dad the next day that you
left me with this person and he was like
oh he's harmless he I was like he was
groping he was trying to kiss me I don't
know what could have happened like
this is not okay but I was 13 so I just
like I I a lot of things that happened
to me I thought was normal I thought
everybody went through this I thought
everybody was dragged by their hair down
the stairs I thought everybody was
punched in the face I thought everybody
was choked I mean I I thought this was
normal this was a normal upbringing
um
but it damaged me so bad that
I I still can't really function as it
emotionally
I I I can't really function as a normal
person because
I feel unhappy every single day of my
life
I wake up and I just feel unhappy
I'm like I have nothing to look forward
to because I just don't let myself
be happy because I feel like if I'm
happy
it will end something will happen and
then I'll get disappointed so I'd just
rather not get disappointed and not look
forward to anything or find happiness
it's better to be miserable because then
you just don't get disappointed
and it's just better and sometimes I I'm
just contemplating like it's just better
that I wasn't around
uh I have that feeling every single day
I try to work through it I I try to
medicate I try to
you know have a holistic approach to
mental health and stuff because I don't
want to start taking
pills because I've already done that
um so I just don't want to I don't want
to be my mom and that scares me and
that's what scares me from having kids
because
what if my mom was normal before she had
me
and I triggered something in her and
what happens if I have kids and this
happens to me and I will I will create a
human being that's me
and I don't want that
so it scares me a lot
it's horrible how one or two traumatic
childhood experiences can impact every
day of your adult life yeah I mean not
that you had you had many more sounds
like with your mom but yeah I every time
my phone rings and it's a private number
I literally want to throw up it's it it
still scares me that she will somehow
beat me again and and when I check my
Facebook messages or my email
every single day I think there's gonna
be an email from her and it's gonna be
bad because the last image she sent me
she she said that I'm disgusting human
being and I will I will kill myself just
like my dad did my real dad he hung
himself
we did he
he was 62 years old he was an alcoholic
and he he never stopped drinking his
entire adult life he was sober for six
months drunk for six months and it was
just like that
um and he had two kids after me
I've never met them because
they have so much trauma in our life in
their life already from having a dad
that was an alcoholic and their mom was
very abusive so I didn't want to get
into their life and then just disappear
because I can't be there all the time
because they live in a whole different
country so I've just never never took
that plunge to talk to them because I
don't want to make them disappointed
but yeah he hung himself the last time
he was supposed to go to rehab he just
couldn't take it so he hung himself and
uh
they uh They Carried him out apparently
which I didn't know uh in front of the
kids on a stretcher
and their mom made them watch
and and apparently their mom said to to
my my stepsister that now there's nobody
who can give you candy
so yeah it's
it's hard
um I I grew up in a very harsh
environment and thankfully I had my
stepdad to think for a lot of good
things in my life
um
I am I am a much stronger person today
but I still am very unhappy
and miserable
I still have Suicidal Thoughts every
single day and I still think world would
be better off without me in it so I
still have that every day but I try to
be strong and try to think about it
but I know and I think a lot of people
see us
if we were only only fans girls or Do
Porn or whatever I think they see us as
bad people but we're not
uh some of us are just going through
things and we're just trying to find
ways to cope with it and just find ways
to have somebody that loves you
unconditionally and I think that's a lot
a lot of us girls
do that because we've had parents or
somebody that did bad things to us and
we don't really know how to channel that
and work through it so we kind of seek
attention especially for men and it
feels good because we're they're
validating that what we do if it's if
it's professional porn if it's just only
fans or escorting or whatever it is in
the sex industry
we're just trying to find somebody that
will love us unconditionally
um
and I think a lot of people think that
we're cheap or we're hoarse or this or
it's not what it's about because a lot
of us just wanted to be appreciated
by somebody because a lot of
a lot of my friends for example don't
have anybody in their life like I have a
husband so I have that support but a lot
of us don't
so we're alone in this and I don't think
people see that they just see oh she's
cheap she's a [__] she does this you
know she does this for money or whatever
but it's not only that there is so much
more emotional trauma behind what we're
doing than just we're doing this for
money
or fame or whatever
we're more than that
but we're that because of something has
happened to us
and I love I like I love all my fans
they're very sweet and they're very
encouraging and I have to say like a lot
of times when I have a hard times a lot
of my fans have helped me like I have
I've been able to talk to a lot of them
and it's been nice because a lot of
these guys are like you shouldn't feel
like this you know it's you're you're a
good person we love you
and it does help because if you have a
group of people that don't really know
you know you say that that you're a good
person that means a lot
so I do appreciate that and I feel like
I've grown a lot as a Woman by doing
this but it's also been really really
tough at times
all right Monica thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you wish you
lots of luck from here thank you you're
still young you have lots of lots of
lots ahead of you for sure thank you so
much thank you
I balled all my makeup away